oh here comes the star of rocky himself
everybody Sylvester Stallone logo out
mega all happen again bring a little
kind of magic to the people I can do it
Oh
versus look Kathy 1 197 6 baraka for you
do my name is Sylvester Stallone would
you like whole cabin or do bicep curls
out like you go work the muscles get
them built up yeah touch of a good luck
all right i'll bet effect love children
gold miles good very exciting Oh however
you bother yourself [ __ ] me baby [ __ ] me
me I'm a big fan of your work in the
Twilight series you know me I got
everyone calling over here rocky in the
vampire oh I got turtle life to it only
yeah you want a chance a couple Los
Angeles again y'all go ball mill go run
to the top of the stairs each of you is
gonna do your best impression of me okay
we go contesta number one I was better
than you thought of gumby number to do
an impression of me doing in a
freshening you don't do an impression of
me okay it's not bad but you make it
less easy to understand yeah yeah yeah
you do that
logitech the Academy you coming sooner
rocky 12 the imagine Persian me Apollo
and the best of Casterly Rock
ah
yeah and the winner and the winner my
former rival who then became my friend
mr. pollow courage that you want in my
friend oh you go all the way oh are you
like that Oh fantastic you feel good I
feel fantastic oh oh no hold over Alaska
baby right yeah the one up yeah